big G is the fundamental one Newtons
universal gravitational constant and
that's the one that really tells you in
general terms how much gravitational
force there will be between two objects
can you tell me what the value of big G
is ah no you know you know I'm
struggling especially remembering what
the units are I think it's something
like six point seven times ten to the
minus eleven it's six point six seven
times ten to the minus eleven but I
always have to look up what the units
are that one I'd actually have to look
up why are you looking in your wallet
cuz I keep it because I keep it yes I
have guessed it right and I can even
give you the unit's now allowance is a
little kind of his wallet he's got it
well this is something very useful these
that I guess I guess actually from some
scientific journals film mag give you
this it's six point six seven times
something identical something but that's
not very helpful and it's got some
fundamental constants I know most of
these fundamental causes are three
significant figures but because I don't
use big G very often I usually have to
look up what that is but I have just
about remembered it right to two
significant figures why don't I need to
know them maybe because they're built
into my calculator so that whenever I
actually do a calculation I'll just
press the big G button yes always
carried around with me just in case I
need it
yep yeah it's very handy if you're doing
if you're stuck in a in a delayed train
or got a few spare hours doing something
it's always good to have it there and
you can doodle around think about things
have the constants in front of you
well a very important symbol for us is
of course the strength of the
gravitational force on the surface of
the earth that's the thing that keeps us
firmly footed on the ground well with G
particularly big G it's all about
gravity and I'm partial gravity because
it is to my mind the most important
force in the universe the quantum
mechanical way of thinking about forces
that the microscopic way of thinking
about forces is that there are particles
that kind of mediate the force a
particle goes from one place to another
and tells you no tells one object to be
attracted but or repulsed by another
object and so that's that's sort of the
way we tend to picture the the forces of
electromagnetism where the particle that
does that of photons but also the forces
the whole nuclei together and so on the
nuclear forces but for gravity we don't
really have that picture I mean we
occasionally sort of try to sketch out a
picture like that and then the particle
that mediates the force that tells
things how to attract each other and
it's called the graviton but we don't we
don't have a fool theory that actually
allows us to understand gravity in that
way the way we do for the other forces
well if we recall those experiments that
Galileo did from the Leaning Tower of
Pisa so let me try and draw the Leaning
Tower of Pisa well big G is what we
would call the gravitational constant
and it's a fundamental constant of
nature comes in to Newton's laws of
gravity and Einsteins laws of gravity
little G is what we would talk about in
terms of local gravity so the
gravitational acceleration that we feel
say here on earth which is 9.8 meters
per second per spekt second so anyway if
we imagine Gallic Galileo sitting up
here with a lead ball on its sphere
little G is just the force of gravity
here on the surface of the earth so it's
you know if you drop something on the
surface of the earth it's how far
something will accelerate under gravity
9.81 meters per second every second is
how much faster it gets so but at some
level that's a very local and kind of
parochial sort of thing and let's
imagine him dropping this so the sphere
comes down to here under the force of
gravity and the gravitational force of
course is given by the mass of the red
sphere times G then what G tells us is
how far the object will fall from the
time
Galileo releases it to fall under the
force of gravity and the distance s it
travels s is then just equal to one-half
of G times T squared where T is the time
it's formed so after one second this
thing will have fallen by G upon two in
one second and then if we were put in
there 9.8 over two that tells us it's
fallen about four point nine meters if
you take a smaller planet like Mars so
let's imagine that we've got Mars that's
smaller than the earth by about that
much it's a little bit less dense as
well but not much less dense they like
the average density of Earth and Mars
are about the same and then a bit
smaller still we have we have the moon
our moon and G is different on on those
three different materials so on as I've
said on the earth G is equal to nine
point eight and we get 9.8 meters per
second squared and we give it that
symbol but on Mars G is about one third
of G on earth and on the moon it's about
one fifth and if you recall when the
astronauts went to the moon they were
even their heavy spacesuit was able to
do very impressive jumps on the moon and
that's simply because that their muscles
had less gravitational force to overcome
there we go so with Isaac Newton we had
a very simplistic form of gravity and
this is the way most of us think about
gravity today which is just two massive
objects pulling each other together
we've moved over to this alliance tiny
in view where the gravity is a
distortion of space itself so for me
I've used in the past this idea of
gravitational lensing so let's imagine
that the seat cushion here is our
space-time so it's it's two dimensions
of space and we're going to warp it in
into a third dimension using my fist so
my fist represents a very massive object
say a black hole or a galaxy or even a
cluster of galaxies you can see that
it's made this sort of dimple in space
in our analogy and what's going to
happen is that any object coming near
this massive object is going to feel the
consequence of this space-time being
warped have this this ball this is going
to be another object and it's just
happily making its way around through
this neighborhood and it encounters this
warping space-time and what happens is
that its path gets deflected the exact
same sort of thing can happen with light
and so we have say a light source in the
distance distant universe say another
galaxy it's emitting light this light is
following the same path that the ball
did and the light path also gets
deflected and so now the light changes
course okay so let's imagine that we're
actually sitting at a telescope we're
sitting over here at a telescope in our
on earth
and we're looking out in this general
direction we detect the light coming
from this distant galaxy after it's been
bent but of course we don't know it's
been bent in our view light travels in a
straight line so we think it's come in
this direction and in fact we don't see
the original source in its original
location we see an image of it over here
and simply by measuring the angle that
this light has been deflected between
where it came from and where we actually
see it we can use
general relativity to measure the mass
of this deflecting object and it doesn't
matter if this is a massive galaxy that
we can see or if it's a big lump of
invisible dark matter gravitational
lensing is the tool that lets us measure
its mass so we go back to my fist here
and we've said that the light coming in
this direction has been deflected and
made it to our telescope over here but
there's no reason that the light coming
around this side of the galaxy can't be
deflected as well and in that case we
see not one but two objects two images
of the same object but spaced out
further apart on the sky so once in a
while when you end up with things
absolutely perfectly aligned so you end
up with a object that's being lens the
lens and us all in an absolutely perfect
straight line then in that case the
light from the object that's being lens
can actually go around the lens any way
any side of the lens and so instead of
just producing a multiple image or
distorted image you end up producing a
perfect ring of light in the sky and
that phenomenon is called an Einstein
ring after Einstein who actually
predicted that this phenomenon should be
observed out there in the universe
you